you got no money here's what's up it's
called Craigslist there's a button
within for sale called free click it
people are giving away old TVs old
couches video games for free you click
the button you go yo I'm coming to your
house I'm picking it up you pick it up
you don't have transportation good you
carry a [__] chair on a bus in the
[__] Subway people look at you who
gives a [__] [__] them next you come
home I know you got a cell phone take a
picture of the [__] chair create a
Facebook account there's something
called Facebook Marketplace you post it
you put the chair on for 20 bucks
somebody's gonna message you and buy it
off of you you can do that 50 times a
month and make three thousand dollars a
month and now you have money